aux abords d'un banal checkpoint dans le
nord-ouest syrien
des virologues se glissent parmi les
militaires pour identifier plus
efficacement les citoyens atteints du
coc vite 19
la procédure est simple les médecins
prennent la température des occupants de
chaque voiture
de quoi rassurer cet automobiliste s'est
très bien notre syrie en a besoin
les patients soupçonné d'avoir contracté
le virus sont prises en charge dans les
hôpitaux de campagne déployés par
l'armée syrienne
les infrastructures ils sont vétustes et
leurs capacités sanitaires sont minimes
lohan jeff the children estime que le
nord-est syrien dispose de moins de 30
lits dans des unités de soins intensifs
ainsi que des respirateurs pour adultes
et un seul pour enfants si le patient a
de la fièvre et de la toux
ils restent ici 48 heures nous
l'examinons en parallèle nous le
traitons par des moyens conventionnels
nous lui donnons à boire des anti fièvre
et s'il n'ya aucune amélioration nous
transférons le patient à l'hôpital
central de hama et de homs
l'ambition pour les prochains jours et
d'augmenter le nombre de cliniques
mobiles et de concevoir un site
d'accueil des personnes confinées la
pandémie a cependant permis de faire
cesser les bombardements entre la
turquie et l'armée syrienne dans la
région plusieurs médecins personnels
humanitaires confirment le respect du
cessez le feu
de quoi permettre aux syriens meurtri
par neuf ans de guerre de bénéficier
d'une meilleure aide humanitaire